we purchased eight new macbook pros in a
variety of configurations to make the
most valuable m1 pro and max videos you
could find and i think we absolutely
succeeded over the last month with many
videos that have discoveries that no one
else mentioned anywhere on the web and
after all the crazy in-depth testing
people asked what are you gonna do with
the machines well as you know one of
them was sent off to matthew in canada
after he won our 2500 and one macbook
pro giveaway some of course will be sold
and some of them we're going to keep
here for long term testing and
comparisons but this exact 3 500 16 inch
m1 max bucket pro is going straight back
to apple and in this video i'll explain
exactly why and cover probably the
toughest choice to make this year and my
honest opinion about it after almost one
month of use now if you watch some of
the m1 max videos you'll know that this
is an absolutely amazing machine the
performance in this 4.7 pound package is
astonishing now sure the 5600m graphics
card in the 16 inch last year was really
fast but we have never seen such a huge
leap in technology in just one year of
course apple has unapologetically backed
out of many of their previous decisions
some that annoyed people like the touch
bar another is that straight-up made
people buy windows machines like having
ports and an sd card built in and now
they even brought back magsafe but made
it even better with braided cables and
fast charging now nobody asked for
better speakers because they were
already the best but they somehow
improved them with super low deep bass
the webcam is also hugely improved and
each thunderbolt port has its own
dedicated controller meaning that the
three ports are more like six this year
and even the keyboard feels improved
over last year of course the display is
absolutely gorgeous as well now no it is
not perfect but no other laptop can
touch it and i'll cover more about this
in my full m1 max review which will be
coming out soon so if you guys want to
see it make sure you're subscribed by
clicking that circle below and with that
you can help us reach our goal of 1
million subscribers we would absolutely
appreciate it what is even more
impressive is the sheer performance this
16-inch macbook pro is a beast and there
is not a single laptop out there that
can match it especially if you care
about it actually being a laptop now i'm
sure some of them have better rap
performance for example the razer blade
advance rtx 3080 and that thing scored
140 000 points in geekbench more than
double what this m1 max's 32 graphics
offer but when it came time for real
world performance the m1 max excelled in
multiple ways and blew away are already
high expectations and i'll show you
exactly why heck even compared to a full
on desktop computer like my 15 000 mac
pro this 3500 macbook punches way above
its weight it's basically david versus
goliath now i expected that regular 4k
video exporting would be faster and my
goodness it is literally being almost
twice as fast for the type of footage
that most people work with but what i
didn't expect were the results when i
threw the absolute toughest footage that
there is to work with my mac pro's
processor is roughly 15 faster under
load and the graphics are 47 more
powerful all while using up to seven
times more power to get this performance
now in my comparison i kept pushing the
macbook harder and harder and harder to
see where it would crack and it just
wouldn't and in the last test where no
encoders are helping it work faster it
still managed to beat out my 15 000 mac
pro in a test where both the cpu and the
gpu were completely maxed out and it did
so on battery power and for less than a
quarter of the price and that also
includes the amazing display the
speakers and more so with all this
raving about this machine and the
performance being so good why in the
world would i be returning this silver
beast of a laptop well the truth is it
is actually a very tough choice but
first let me tell you about our sponsor
if you've been thinking about making
your own website squarespace is
seriously the best way to go you can
build a great looking website like we
did with literally no web making
experience it doesn't matter if you want
a portfolio a blog ecommerce or anything
else you just simply choose a template
and customize blocks of text and images
and easily move them around it is
incredibly simple it's very affordable
and ours have been running flawlessly
for over three years bringing in tons of
traffic thanks to its built-in seo tools
start your free two-week trial with no
credit card required by going to
squarespace.com or by using our custom
link down below and when you are ready
to launch you will save 10 off your
first purchase of a website or domain
now like many of you i have always
purchased 15-inch macbook pros and then
later 16-inch macbook pros because they
were so much more powerful than apple's
13-inch macbooks for two reasons the
first one is obviously the performance
apple's larger macbooks have typically
had processors that have double the
cores with much more cpu performance but
an even bigger difference was the
graphics going from super weak
integrated graphics to dedicated
graphics made an insane difference in
real world performance and tasks that i
regularly did even with the cheapest
larger macbook so much so that buying an
1800 13-ish macbook pro was almost a
rip-off compared to just buying the base
16-inch the second part was the display
size for those of you guys that do video
editing like i do having that larger
screen made a world of a difference if
you're even spending say an hour on a
video project of course the struggle was
with weight in size as the 13 inch was
so much more compact and portable and
for many people including myself that
size was just way more enjoyable to use
day to day now when the m1 macbooks came
out suddenly we had this unbelievable
change where even the fanless m1 macbook
air performed astonishingly well and
could handle any work that most people
would throw at it and sure the m1 cpus
had absolutely insane performance but
for those that needed extra graphics
performance this was the weak spot for
the machine and it could get
significantly slower if you do that kind
of work now because of that if i needed
great total performance i still have to
go back to a 16-inch macbook pro despite
so many drawbacks like way worse battery
life loud fan noise and much bigger size
that is where this current paradigm
shift came in and for the first time
ever in macbook history you could spec
the new 14-inch macbook pro exactly the
same as the larger 16 inch size with up
to 64 gigabytes of ram an m1 max 32 core
processor and 8 terabytes of ssd space
but with that exciting change we also
had two changes that made this seemingly
easy choice much more difficult and that
put me and many of you guys back to
square one and i was sitting there
contemplating how to make the correct
choice because of five key points now if
you guys watched apple's keynote it
seemed like you just choose the size you
want but at max tech we found some major
differences the first one was battery
life now one of the big reasons in the
past to get a 13 inch was the better
battery life but with these new 14 inch
and 16 inch apple silicon machines the
16 inch gets significantly better
battery life with the 14 inch barely
improving over the past 13 inch machines
while the 16 has insane battery life and
of course performance both for simple
tests and heavy loads the second was of
course the screen size with that size
still being preferable for productivity
tasks and the third was fan noise with
the 16 inch running cooler and quieter
than the 14 inch and then we have actual
real world performance and the fact that
the 16 inch is now only 200 more
expensive for an arguably better machine
in many ways we found that apple
literally artificially limited the
performance of the 14 inch m1 max even
if the computer is fully charged and
running very cool the 32 core graphics
in the 14 inch at best runs 200
megahertz lower than the 16 inch which
in simple tasks shows a noticeable
difference but when you push the
machines the difference can grow up to
36
which is massive for a 200 difference we
did a ton of testing for many specific
use cases so if you haven't yet watched
that video you definitely should check
it out after this one but i have to say
that after all those tests i totally
understand why apple artificially is
limiting the performance because even if
the much smaller cooling assembly isn't
being maxed out the 40 smaller battery
would just be killed so much faster if
they gave it the full performance which
is also why it does not have the high
power mode and after all of that testing
i was convinced that the 16 inch is the
right choice for anybody that cares
about performance but in the coming
weeks of use i slowly started to change
my mind every time i use the 16 inch
after using the 14 inch yes the 14 inch
has worse performance and yes the 14
inch fans could be audible where the 16
inch fans will stay silent under the
same use cases and yes the battery life
difference is noticeable in real world
use and yes the six inch display is nice
to have when you're pushing the machine
along with the noticeably better
speakers the 16 inch macbook is a
clearly superior machine and for only
200 more it just makes total logical
sense but what i found is that you can't
always just go by logic and sometimes
the machine that just feels better and
makes you want to take it along with you
is the right choice even if it is full
of compromises every time i take the 16
inch with me i don't enjoy using it
anywhere near as much as the 14 inch
machine because of how chunky and heavy
it is i we haven't had a macbook this
heavy for a long time it's really
noticeable even going from the intel's
16 inch of last year because it did get
significantly thicker and heavier where
the 14 inch is actually slightly thinner
and it didn't gain that much in weight
what i have found is that even though
the 14 inch is slower it is still fast
enough for everything that i throw at it
and in those times where something takes
a minute or two longer i just don't
notice it because you know it's just
doing its thing and with that there is
literally no other 14 inch machine that
packs this amount of performance into
this size on the market and even if the
battery life is worse than the 16 inch
it still has the best battery life out
of any high performance 14 inch laptop
and of course it performs the same exact
on battery power as it does when it's
plugged in which is rare with that for
those times that i do need insane
battery life i can literally power it
and at the same time charge the battery
by a cheap usb type-c power bank even if
i'm pushing the machine which is another
amazing achievement thanks to apple
silicon so after weeks of real world use
i am making the decision that i never
thought i would i'm making the choice
that does not make logical sense but one
that i'm certain about now and i am
returning the machine that i thought
would be my long-term performance laptop
and that is the 16-inch m1 macbook pro
and i'm surprisingly going with the
illogical 14-inch macbook pro despite
its many drawbacks and for those of you
stuck in the same decision loop if
you're somebody who enjoys having a
smaller machine i can now say that i
just wouldn't hesitate to make the same
choice that i did as well
thank you guys for watching hopefully
you guys enjoyed our series of videos
where we did the most in-depth testing
if you did go ahead and click that
circle above to subscribe and help us
reach our goal of a million subscribers
check out one of those great comparisons
right over there this has been maxtec
and i'll see you in the next video
[Music]